is it easy to for you to watch yourself
do you like watching yourself
but i'm good
because i love watching yourself well
maybe i'm always good for you
this is the 50th anniversary
of two women
and
you were not originally cast in in the
mother's world you're originally cast as
a daughter but you said no i should play
the mother ana magnani was cast as the
mother originally yes so what'd you do
hit her in the back of the head with a
thing
how did how did you end up
in in this part
no
the seeker when he read the book he said
that manani would be perfect for the
mother and i would be perfect for the
daughter
so he went to sierra nemanjani and she
said oh yes i love the story very much
but i prefer
a little girl and otherwise sofia and
myself we are going to eat each other on
the screen
i don't know why she thought that but
because i'm not that kind of a person
but anyway she was very unhappy if she
if i wasn't
so the seeker said well i'm very sorry
tried to convince her still with the
telegrams and things but she said no no
no
no no no just you choose somebody else
i was in
france
i was doing a film with jean-gaban
a
victorious sent me a telegram saying
don't worry you are going to be chezira
which is the name of the character if
you don't know
and
and a little girl of
14 13 14 years old she's going to be
your daughter and i said my god i'm not
even a man i don't know i don't know
what to do what to do
and so he said don't worry don't worry
we will be
together and
i would we will be we will
do a wonderful picture together i'm sure
of it
so i said to myself if the zika says so
i follow him
and my life changed completely
so i have to thank her namani and she
said no no
no no no no
no no no because i'm not a bad person
no no it's true
now ed how old were you when you met
carla ponti
i was very young
were you you were 14
15 15.
and this was
this was at this this beauty contest yes
that you finished second in yeah
i always finished second in the beauty
contest i don't know why
this i don't get
this i don't get well maybe i said maybe
if you had one you would have gone on to
do something else
what other than i don't know
if you are so secure of what you say you
should tell me what you i'm so far from
secure
i don't even have a car that can drive
me to secure
but he would change your life
because he believed in you as an actress
and and
and your relationship with him was a
glorious one two beautiful sons and he
even taught to me how to eat
well this i have to hear no
no i want to eat because one day we went
to a restaurant
and i
ordered an omelette
and i picked up the fork
and the knife
and he said don't do that because
because the omelette you only cut it
with a fork
since then i never ordered the omelette
again
you